j'ai décidé pour voir le l'origine de
feu j'ai parlé il faut il faut rester
calme
on va tous sauvés par l'échafaud g
ouvrir la fenêtre et on a inventé par
l'échafaud on a descendu comme ça
[Musique]
au deuxième étage y ait du casque et qui
à s'éclater sur sur moi après j'ai eu le
feu dans dans mon visage dans mes bras
et à partir de cet instant j'ai compris
que ce pain c'est parti incendie mais
c'est un grand incendie parce que j'ai
commencé à vue tout le monde ils ont en
train de crier il ya beaucoup de vos
seins sortent ils ont été bloqués dont 6
e
il fait il a pris tous les couloirs et
j'ai vu les voisins qui sont ils ont été
coincés dans le bâtiment ils n'ont pas
trouvé de solution ils sont commencé à
sauter du cinquième étage
j'ai vu des deux femmes est sauté de
veau moir sont était mort franchement je
peux pas penser il n'ya pas y'a rien
avaler parce que j'ai pas l'habitude
d'avoir voir le feu à voir des gens sont
en train de mourir devant moi et et des
gens qui hurlent qui crie partout dans
le bâtiment et a le feu qui vous savez
pas de dos il va sortir il n'y a qu'une
issue
cet échafaudage sur lequel s'élance
aussi depuis la rue plusieurs
volontaires
ça a été un peu la guerre quoi ça a été
un peu un jour de guerre ya eu vraiment
du courage il ya été affronter les feux
même les flammes
les voisins et on m'appelle de moins
qu'un jour il m'appelle rsa valero
s'assemblent ça ça fait trop bien c'est
pour le moral et parfois je trouve les
petits que j'ai sauvé est en train de
jouer
franchement je suis fier de ce que j'ai
fait un acte de bravoure que l'état
pourrait récompenser en le régularise
raison des queues
j'ai fait un
un acte noble et il faut me donner les
papiers je vais avoir un travail je veux
avoir une vie normale
oubliez le maire qui est venu discuter
avec moi et m'a promis mater vous
inquiétez pas tu vas forte papier on va
regretter situation et fallait pas que
tu perds tu as fait un bon geste et vous
inquiétez pas parce que moi je croyais
que novembre à mai en tunisie c'est fini
parce que les pattes bruxelles pourrait
avoir une réponse rapidement
le préfet de seine saint denis va le
rencontrer mardi prochain pour étudier
personnellement son dossier et je me
suis trouvé dans un centre dans un
centre dans le xivème un centre des gens
malades et sont bien ils n'ont pas le
même cas que moi déjà des gens tox
comprendre la craque avant
il ya des morts iliad est devant moi
tous les jours
il ya des conditions franchement je peux
pas te dire les conditions dans le
centre où j'ai été moi g
il est resté quatre ans pour avoir un
logement et dans mes quatre ans j'ai
travaillé je n'aimais filtre paix j'en
ai mon salaire j'en ai tout est super g
pour journée tout le temps normalement
j'en sais pas pourquoi il restait trois
ans dans ce centre et dès que je sais
sortie de 60 tout est changé
[Musique]
c'est incomparable avec la carte d'un an
et dix ans est franc joue aussi
incomparable mais même les patrons même
dans les sociétés et aux autres troncs
sérieuses et papa maman ou garder carey
cpc france mousser un comparé à
[Musique]
suivi bros il avance j'ai eu ma carte et
mon logement j'ai un bon travail j'aime
le boulot que je fais si tout va bien
tout dans nos trois ans pas tu peux
habillés de costumes des pompiers